la première fois vous avez rencontré
cyril oui est ce qu'il a essayé de vous
draguer ou pas première fois qu'il est
question
la première fois que j'ai rencontré
c'est cyril n'a jamais cessé de me
draguer il a pris le bonne comme ça de
trucs il s'est mis à danser avec en les
jetant dans tous les sens ah oui j'étais
moi c'était ce type il s'est mis à
danser autour de moi en me disant salut
toi ça va et je me suis là je les quais
[Rires]
mais il n'a jamais cherché à me draguer
du tout cela dit ouais cela dit oui j'ai
appris en faisant une émission de radio
avec lui mais qu' il avait eu un petit
penchant pour moi alors je sais pas s'il
a dit ça pour rigoler ou pour plaisanter
mais il avait dit d'une façon un peu
sérieuse qui m'a un peu troublé je ne le
cache pas quand on sait que à cette
époque là effectivement que j'étais à
tf1 il avait eu un petit penchant pour
moi et il ne l'avait jamais dit et je ne
mettais absolument pas venu à l'esprit
j'aurais pu dire oui site était
célibataire pardon aurait pu dire oui si
tu avais été cédée bat à l'époque de mes
fins j'aurais peut-être oui succombé au
charme de série parce qu'il est petit il
est très drôle
[Applaudissements]